[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me boy I hope Shaun
keeps this part of me intro oh my god
hello everybody welcome to the
middlemost podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Millburn I
am Ryan nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists we are back baby yeah
yeah well we didn't really go anywhere
but but we're back in studio and this is
episode 113 today we're going to talk
about the new year so Ryan how was your
Christmas it was amazing you know why
why because I spent it with the people
and matter the most
I'm sorry you weren't there we're
actually recording this before Christmas
I'm also spending my Christmas with the
people that matter the most I'm actually
gonna be alone this Christmas oh dude
that's like the perfect Christmas gift
for you it really is like we totally
actually right after this I have to take
Bex and Ella to the airport they're
heading up L was doing like three
Christmases here so we had hours in
California she's doing Minnesota and
she's gonna be back in Montana with her
father Christmas while they were in town
yeah yeah yeah cool so like we did you
guys do a tree and stuff no we did it we
did a tree but like we didn't do
physical gifts for her we did experience
real gifts oh so there wasn't like the
the requisite unwrapping of unnecessary
items you know it's funny I was gonna
save this for the recommended value
section I think he needs added value or
rusty we're back in studio I added value
by in studio we mean we're in our friend
Matt Diavel kitchen yes
shout out to Matthew Vella and that's
over in the corner right now eating
lasagna
he's so Italian no no yeah for that I
was gonna say with the other day I had a
couple things so I'll just say this
right now you the other day you sent me
a text and you're like hey we're gonna
go
look at Christmas lights do you want to
go so Mariah and I went with you and Bex
and Ella to go look at Christmas lights
I don't like I don't know why like that
is something I used to do all the time
and I haven't really gone out of my way
to do that so thank you very much
yeah you were giving for gifting me that
experience well I think I think you just
you used the key phrase they're gone out
of my way I mean it it is like truly out
of the way like literally geographically
we went over to Beverly Hills because
they have the most posh lights oh yeah
and so we drove over to Beverly Hills
found a parking space at a meter and
then walked around and just checked out
the lights and and didn't buy anything
on Rodeo Drive but we still got to enjoy
the the experience of taking a look at
the lights that's the first time we've
ever been on Rodeo Drive yeah my god I
feel like I feel like I lost ten
thousand dollars just walking down that
Street well that's how much it was the
park is a meter just ten thousand
dollars an hour anyway today we're gonna
talk about the new year and we are we
are back in studio we're gonna be a back
in studio a lot more as you know we're
building a new podcast and film studio
in the meantime we will we'll be set up
in Matt's kitchen hopefully I thought
for as long as they let us do this by
the way check out his podcast you've
heard him on our podcast before it's
called the ground up show all right Ryan
this is the time of year the people
reset they reassess and I'm talking
about the new year so so this comes out
on on New Year's Day 2018 when people
start to refocus so we've got some
questions that people are asking us and
we've got some questions for social
media as well do you want to go ahead
and jump in let's do it man let's get
into these voicemails
all right well our first voicemail is
from Gretta and what I would say
Melbourne Australia some people might
say Mel Bourne
that's something pronounce my name
sometimes but I know in Australia it's
Melbourne Melbourne Australia although
in Scotland that's how they pronounce my
last name to Melbourne yeah
Joshua fields Melbourne now Josh you
correct me if I'm wrong I usually do
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the the way that we pronounce things we
should pronounce them in the vernacular
that or yeah like using the vernacular
of the country were from correct so like
we would say Melbourne right so is that
how we should say because cuz like I
know like I'll say Lao like hey I want
to allow people who are like oh Laos
right and in and in the states right we
say Laos right so like I will say Laos
like just to not confuse people or what
I don't know am i if I had to be my
thinking about this too much no I've had
to be prescriptive about it you would
yes you you would use the dialect from
which you are accustom and in which
you're in right now which would be
standard American English also known as
a standard written English and a lot of
textbooks but that said I'm not that
prescriptive and I think you could be a
descriptivists about this and you can
say tomato you could say hey Josh can
you get me a tamale look you know it's
funny as people yet they say tomato
tomahto
but I don't who says tomahto British
people and Australia people though oh
yeah I think they say tomahto I see
alright alright Gretta from tomato
Australia I wanted to ask the question
about your day-to-day planning and
organizing I feel like I am the type of
person that loves to organize to be
organized yet doesn't stay organized so
if you guys have any comments or
suggestions on like whether you use
online daily planners or organizers or
the physical ones I'd love to have some
help now right I'm looking at you and
you're Franklin planner and all of us
cabs the worst person to ask this
question - it's funny I was thinking
that you're also the worst person to ask
about this question maybe maybe I'm also
the best person ask because I'm so bad
what shouldn't you tell her what you
doing that's what you should tell Gretta
which you should not do first love
dude I am so pumped to go to Australia
it's gonna be so much fun Greta we're
excited to go to Melbourne Australia
also did I say alright yeah you're
perfect man how to plan well here's I
was actually having this conversation
yesterday with a with a mentee here's
what I would say first and foremost step
number one Greta you have to figure out
what is it that you want to accomplish
each day that is first and foremost so
during the week Monday through Friday
you've probably got work great so what
is your schedule or what do you need to
accomplish each day Monday through
Friday Saturday and Sunday might look a
little bit different what do you what do
you want to accomplish on those days
what do you think is that a good step
number one Josh well I thought this was
a good question because of of the sort
of new year thing and people want to lay
it's almost like a resolution like I
want to become more organized so what
you're saying there is identify your
priorities and so the new year thing it
quite often it's like well I have these
17 resolutions right and and then all of
a sudden they all go by the wayside
because you become overwhelmed so if yes
if you say step number one but then and
you figure out well here are my
seventeen priorities that's a good start
but guess what you're probably I need to
get all 17 of those important things
done over the course of the day
absolutely and I think that's why it's
important to write these out because we
have to get clear on what we want to
accomplish and then I think from there
it's it's getting clear on okay now what
are we actually able to accomplish right
right and so if if you look at that list
of 17 items you might say okay what what
is a Tim Ferriss thing but don't say
like what is the one thing if I
accomplished today out of all of these
17 items that will render the rest of
these less important or unnecessary
altogether right and and I find that
quite often with me if I have a to-do
list the the thing that makes it to-do
list
easy to tackle is I'll go in there and
I'll just delete stuff from it or what
I'll do is if I'm terrified deleting it
I have two lists you could actually see
it on my computer right now there's a
today list but here's what I have to do
today so I'm like a computer it's on my
phone I just use a little memo pad
here's what must be done today
and then if it gets too full I say okay
I'm gonna move that to a someday list
and that tells me it's not a real
priority in my life but like for example
next week I'm not going to be with with
family most of the week and so I'm gonna
just view myself I have this whole list
of here's some stuff I want to do
someday I need to reassess my term life
insurance and then I will take time to
like go through all these boring mundane
tasks and not things I must do
absolutely today although we trick
ourselves the only thing like we trick
ourselves into saying totally I've got
to do all this stuff and I have to get
it done immediately and it's hard to
prioritize when everything is an
emergency yeah and we put pressure on
ourselves to to do too much in a day
it's like we have this long list of
stuff and for some reason and I know a
lot of people out there feel this way
like for me if I've got ten things
knocking five of them off it makes me
feel almost inadequate like oh I'm not I
can't handle all this or I can't
accomplish enough in a day and I start
to beat myself up yeah I'm not Taipei
enough I'm not hard charge especially in
the culture that we ran yeah yeah and so
I think what you're saying there if you
have 10 items you cross five of them off
you're saying no to those five that are
less important so you can say yes to the
five that are more important absolutely
I actually have the opposite dilemma
sometimes sometimes I'll say I've got
these five things like there's the thing
a phone call to make today but some of
the lists I've been dreading for several
days and it's been on my today list for
like three days and I'm like wait a
minute
this is it was today yesterday so I
don't have a yesterday list and so just
it's sort of stay it stays on this is a
phone call I'm dreading to make are you
calling is it the call to clear the
psychic together
Diana Warwick
she knows I'm calling you were you
worried about what the future holds
[Music]
if your psychic would read it worried
about the future what the future holds
um man you just blew my mind
anyway what I'll do sometimes I've got
these five things that need to get done
right yeah but they're the more
difficult things to do and so instead I
will like pacify myself I'll just get on
YouTube and watch a video
really quick because that's my crack and
then all of a sudden it's four hours
later there's drool and ketchup on my
shirt I don't even know why I was
catching my shot wasn't I walked in on
you one time there was drooling ketchup
everywhere who's on the wall and what I
realize is like man let me reward myself
with say a youtube binge after I
complete these five tasks what I'll do
and here's the messed up part about that
phone call that I need to make today
he's gonna take all of three minutes
maybe if it goes really well to go ten
minutes and then it's done and even even
if it goes badly like it's out of the
way and then I can get on to drooling on
myself in front of the screen a few
other things here so she mentioned like
she loves being organized but she
doesn't stay organized it's like I sang
with writers the writers don't like
writing that they like having written
and what she's saying is she doesn't
like organizing she likes being
organized right yeah I think we all Ryan
you don't like organize oh yeah no I I
don't like wanna say it feels to me like
what not anymore because I I have
incorporated some some things into my
life that has helped me out a lot with
was scheduling it so I'm still not
perfect at it for sure but definitely
better than you know what I was my 25
year old self but it used to feel
pointless they used to feel like a waste
of time and I don't know why but it was
like this
I don't need be that organized I can
just I can just wing it and fly by the
seat of my pants and be just fine I
think I think I know why though here's
we're joking that you're like the less
organizes the two of us that's because
I'm Fort Knox when it comes to
organization right it's not fair on the
the Library of Congress of my own domain
yes um but that said and that's just cuz
I'm OCD it's not it's an affliction that
I've been that I'm suffering from for
for the last 36 years but with you you
are I I think you're a healthy degree of
organized but but it's not because you
have that tendency to be organized its
you've set up some of these things in
place where you're like I know what my
priorities are I know what my values are
and I know what actions I need to take
and then you also put the appropriate
level of discomfort on yourself and
discontent if you don't get something
done where you're like oh crap I've
really meant to do that and I didn't get
done it was on my list and you you beat
yourself up but not so much that you
like feel bad but enough you're like I
don't want to feel that pain again so I
might as well go ahead and complete this
task because then the task is easier
than the pain I'm gonna feel if I don't
complete it absolutely absolutely
and so what I'll say is organizing as
well planned hoarding right and so the
first thing we want to do if we're
organizing our life is we want to have
less to organize now what does that mean
it could be less stuff to organize the
average American household has 300,000
items in it it's really difficult to
organize 300,000 items I know trust me I
had an ordinal system of boxes and bins
and all the stuff in my basement and
closets in garage and second living room
and spare bedroom and the calls it in
the spare bedroom which was my second
calls that for all the oversized shirts
I didn't wear they were alphabetized and
I realized like you know what like this
stuff is really hard to organize cuz I
have so much of it so if you if you want
to make it easier for you to organize
get rid of the stuff now it might not
just be stuff it might be that you have
too much stuff on your calendar you have
too much stuff on your computer and a
social media occupying your time too
much time sucks with your television
that's on the wall or or these other
activities that you're embarking in that
are embarking on that fill up your
calendar either literally like you've
planned them or you haven't planned them
at all and so you're like well I've got
a free couple hours I'm not gonna focus
on my priorities I'm going to focus on
well I'm not gonna focus on anything
really I'm going to veg out and there's
time for that for sure but but but not
if it's getting in the way of what's
truly important so if you want to
organize your life I found for me having
slack in my calendar is important having
fewer things scheduled in fact last week
you and I cancelled a bunch of
interviews that we had scheduled I will
just tackle these interviews after the
tour and it was like well no like I've
been reprioritizing to focusing on my
health and I'm organizing my calendar in
that fashion where I need that slack in
my
calendar so that I can focus on the
things that are most important so some
practical tips there have a today list
have a some day list Ryan you talked
about having at the beginning of each
day knowing like what are the what are
the things I must accomplish today right
what when I when I was thinking about
greta's question I thought about like
the process I would go through and it
would be very similar to like a
budgeting process with with my money I
mean the same process would apply to my
time if I feel like I'm so overwhelmed I
would take okay I would take you know
the last month what have I been doing
with my time
how about how have I been spending it
what do I how much time do I need what
are things I can say no - I mean you
know kind of putting things into a a
likes once needs list I think that I
think this could also help help a grete
I I think the number one thing for me
though and this is such a simple simple
thing but like my calendar like that is
what that's the that's my Bible that is
like I get up and I know exactly yes
what I want to do each day and I have
that scheduled in my calendar even to
the extent of I had to get something in
the mail yesterday and I knew I wouldn't
get it was over the weekend that I found
this out and I know I wouldn't be able
to get to it until Tuesday so I
literally in my calendar put a little
entry in there hey Ryan get this in the
mail so so that's another thing - Greta
is so figure out what you want to do and
then put that stuff in your calendar and
and treat that thing as gospel and then
honestly like the biggest part of and
this is you know so easy to give advice
I need to like take this advice myself
but taking the action taking massive
action like really really treating that
calendar is gospel and in finding the
leverage to act on on those those things
that you have scheduled in there so it's
like I was thinking about this earlier
when I was thinking about gratis
question yesterday the mentee I was
talking to about this this time
scheduling they asked me well how do you
find the leverage to you know to
get in bed by 10 o'clock if that was one
specific thing I'm like I got to make
sure that I'm in bed by 9:30 or 10
o'clock because I want to be up by 7:00
takes me about an hour to fall asleep so
I try to make sure I'm in bed by no
later than 10 o'clock just make sure
Mariah's there and like some negligee
when we walked in I totally found out
that Matt is into penguins he has some
weird fetish I know I saw that Natalie
walking out in her nightgown in a
penguin outfit apparently that's her
work dress coat no it parently it's
worth its wear pajamas the work day that
was that was really really funny but um
but no no it was mariah is actually
pretty good about saying hey maybe we
should go to bed or hey Ron I'm gonna go
brush my teeth and it's kind of like
that's my cue to get in bed but she was
asking me what is the leverage and you
know what the leverage is is I want to
get up at 7:00 a.m. the leverage is is
an order for me to live a meaningful
life like I've got to be up at 7:00 a.m.
and there are certain things that I want
to do each day and if I don't do those
things I'm not going to feel complete so
the leverage for me is simply forcing
myself to do it because I know that it's
going to make me feel more complete the
following day yeah and I think she asked
like what you know like what what
physical do you use a particular plan or
whatever I think you use whatever is
best for you I mean if you real I was
joking about you don't have a Franklin
planner you know honestly I have a
notebook I mean I use this notebook for
notes but it is I mean it looks like a
crazy persons I mean if I ever like fall
off a roof or something and people find
this they're gonna like what is this I
need some sort of rosetta stone to read
to read this but my calendar I use
Google Calendar and Ryan and I we have a
shared calendars for our work stuff with
minimalist that is HUGE if you have a
like for me and Mariah yeah so for
anyone out there as a partner and you
guys you know are having trouble with
scheduling issues just having a shared
calendar like that for me mariah is huge
and the same thing for us yeah for sure
I mean it and it allows me to see okay
before I even asked Ryan if he's
available at this time I can check his
calendar
and then I can ask him if I don't see
anything on the calendar I'm obviously
nothing's gonna schedule something for
Ryan hey Ryan
schedule to wash my car at 3:30 today
that's it's not gonna happen but yeah
use whatever works best for you and if
you don't know what works best for you
try some different stuff out and and
figure and keep keep the stuff that adds
value let go of the the tools that
aren't adding value there's one thing I
got to throw out here for anyone out
there who is who has trouble scheduling
with clients so for me with with
mentoring Josh you you know how much
hassle I had when I was trying to email
back and forth scheduling times yeah and
and it was a I was happy to have the
hassle but it was like okay here are
some dates no no I'm not available those
dates how about these dates no no I'm
not available those dates how about and
we were going back and forth and then
Josh you actually showed me the tool
schedule once right and this is
basically a tool that I use now when I
have someone sign up for a mentoring
session I send them a link they click on
the link and they have access to my
calendar and they could see exactly when
I'm available so this may not help you
Greta but I'm sure there's someone out
there who has who has clients that they
need to schedule time with and maybe
they're having a hassle like I was yeah
schedule once I probably should to say
that for they added value to but this
seemed like an appropriate time that's
good that's good and and Greta by the
way since you're in Melbourne we'd love
to give you a couple tickets to our
second Melbourne event the first one
sold out really quickly we're doing
seven cities in Australia New Zealand
this year we're gonna be in Perth and
Brisbane and Sydney and Adelaide and
Melbourne twice and then we're going
over to Auckland as well so bunch of
cities over there les is now calm or
just go to the minimalists calm you can
follow our tour dates there but but I'm
not selling anything ready we'll give
you a couple tickets well Sean reach out
to you and get you some tickets while
there are still a few remaining for that
event alright our next question is from
Ryan not the
in front of me they Ryan on the phone in
Connecticut from the age of 15 to about
21 I became quite the workaholic because
I was a very poor poor young kid and I
said no I'm just going to keep working
work work work until I just until I'm
not broke anymore and then waking up as
a 21 year old I'm 21 now I have about
$50,000 in the bank I have no debt but
the negative side is I almost forgot
what it's like to be able to not be a
workaholic to not be I work constantly
because I've been doing it for so many
years over 25 percent of my life so how
do I get away from being such a
workaholic and getting back into finding
the things that I love I know a few
things that I definitely couldn't do
without on a day to day basis I love
going right going running hiking
I love craft beers with my dad but um
anything over about 48 hours of not
working I feel like that tick to go back
to work Josh it's pretty simple man he's
got 50 grand in the bank he should go
buy a Corvette I mean that's a good down
payment no no I think you can actually I
think a Corvette is exactly like it's
right at 50,000 bucks if not you
probably at the previous year's model
exactly yeah all right next question
all right no man Ryan don't go do that
you please don't um actually
congratulations you have a really good
problem on your hands
21 years old he's 21 years old so here's
what he asked
he has no debt right Wow
congratulations you have $50,000 in the
bank as a really bulked up emergency
fund
I assume you're also saving for
retirement Bravo but you do have just
because you have a good problem doesn't
mean that it's not a problem you have a
great problem here and and here's here's
the first thing that I'll say uh first I
want to say is let's talk a talk about
what you what you do have you have a
great work ethic you have 50,000 in the
bank you have no debt but you're also
sibling yeah yeah but let's talk about
what you don't have
you don't have a lot of time you were
time poor right now because you're a
workaholic and and you also have few
responsibilities which is a good thing
so you don't have it doesn't sounding
like you have a wife and kids it doesn't
sound to me like you have a bunch of
people who or you're responsible for
you're probably not leading thousands of
people and so you don't have that that
burden on your shoulders and so this
this sort of obstacle is a self built
obstacle right this is some obstacle
that society or someone else's put in
front of him
although here's the weird thing we have
this duality with work we in American
culture in particular but Western
culture in general we often we praise
people who are the workaholics you work
work work work like you that's what it
was like in our in our culture man for
sure wait I mean like it like you and I
were always trying to be like the first
one in the last one out yeah yeah but if
I flip that on its head for a second
think about this Ryan
we also demonize work at the same time
at the same time so it's like this weird
it's this weird dichotomy because well
he'll heat what he's saying is I really
work too much and maybe that's true but
we don't hear people say you know I just
spend too much time with my family but
it's true there are some people who
probably spend too much time with their
family yeah and and it actually
decreases the quality of the time and I
would argue the same thing with your
work it Ryan if you and I were to work a
hundred hours a week every single week
do nothing but work podcasting and
live-streaming and blogging and the
quality of what we were do we'd get out
a lot of content we'd be like the
paragon of content generation but we
wouldn't be doing anything well we would
the the the the ratio of meaningful
content meaningful creations within that
content would be so low that we'd want
to avoid that and so here's what I'll
say is the problem isn't it isn't work
necessarily right I think people get
great meaning from their work
yeah a lot of people do at least and if
in fact so maybe the problem is not
finding meaning in what you're doing
right and so the other the other problem
that I see in my own life and so I'll
project this on to Ryan from Connecticut
here is you like working a lot because
it's the easiest thing to be in control
of right I mean I don't know about Ryan
you're a lot more balanced than I am for
sure but so yesterday we spent the day
in Santa Monica we were like at the fair
doing Christmasy stuff and and we were
on like the ferris wheel and elves are
on the roller coaster and it was 56
degrees but she wanted to get in the
ocean oh my goodness yeah anyway so
let's have like no they have no they
like no pain receptors no concept of
what cold is right right and so we're
out there and I realized that while
we're out there like man this is I don't
have control of the city like because
Ella is a four year old and and you tell
her to do something unless I heard of
you know physically force her to do
something right I couldn't get her to
eat the snack that she was crying about
five minutes ago I we go find buy an
overpriced kind bar at some little shop
there and then she refuses eat it's not
the kind that I want oh I don't have
control over that right like I want to
eat the damn kind boy what's your deal
you just asked for this and so like it's
easier for me to display okay put my
hands up it so I'm gonna get back to
work get my computer screen in front of
me ready I'm fully in control of that
mmm but my point is sometimes the more
meaningful experiences especially in
retrospect or the experiences we don't
have full control over it's the
collaboration it's the interaction
it's the conversations and some of that
can come through the medium of work of
vocation but sometimes some of it has to
come from outside of the work as well
and one other thing you don't have Ryan
from Connecticut you don't have time to
go running or hiking or have craft beers
with your dad and this house to me like
you need more balance and so Ryan is the
the balanced half of the duo what do you
what do you think well when I
Ryan's Ryan's question what I heard him
saying or heard him asking was is how
what what do I do now that I have
mastered the work that I had that I put
in front of me so what happened is Ryan
set out there's this goal to be
debt-free to have a decent savings and
to do that he had to work a lot sure and
he might have even have found I know for
me I certainly did when I first started
you know managing retail stores there
was way way more joy than there was pain
with it because it was new it was
exciting I was learning something new
and and I think a lot of people they
will have that when they start a new job
once we do it for 50 60 70 80 hours a
week week in and week out it becomes
routine and we become a master at that
particular task right in the problem
with mastering something it's it's great
because we have learned this skill or
been able to learn how to operate in a
certain environment but then our brain
wants to master something else for sure
I mean I think about our own work when
we started the the minimalists comm
seven years ago it was blogging and that
was it yeah yeah and well I can't say
that we fully mastered it like we got to
a point where it felt like you know we
were we were within that realm of
mastery well and when I say mastering
you know it's two to each person's
individual skill set right right all
right so for our for our skill set I
feel like we've you know we've mastered
blogging I mean we are not Seth Godin by
any stretch no we are not leo bababa but
for what we have you know been able to
do for ourselves with the particular
skills that we have I feel like you know
we have mastered is not as much as we've
been able to but um you know I couldn't
imagine how much more we can master it
from here right and so it was like how
do we challenge herself in a different
way and write that longer form and
moving on the books or going out and
doing public speaking which was
terrifying at first and now here's a
weird thing I was just thinking about
some when I was walking over to Matt's
house and I realized that
I get more anxiety about coming into the
in studio episodes and I do live events
now because we've done fewer of these
over the past three or four months yeah
so going to a live event in front of a
thousand people in a theater is less
anxiety-producing than just coming over
here to report this I feel the same way
I know why it is for me it's the mastery
thing though it's like oh you've been
doing this and you eat and and the first
time we I remember the first time you
gave a speech in front of large crowd of
people when we were in New York City oh
don't why are you bringing that up those
my work dude I was the worst talk ever
I forgot half the talk everyone everyone
who was important there has never been
an event where we had that many
important people there like all the
press all of us every single oh my god
2013 and yeah there was a talk that you
had to give my part was easy I was just
reading from the new book we had coming
out I remember when I first look when I
just went blank and I looked at you and
I'm like oh but he just looked at me
like I don't know what you want me to do
right now the funny thing is now after
doing hundreds literally hundreds of
speaking gigs and tour stops we've you
could look at me now and we could
totally bail each other out now yeah
because that dynamic it's that mastery
thing that you're talking about but
going to that first one you're going to
choke but that's part of like that's
where the fear and excitement comes in
is is you're getting better and better
and better into where you get to a point
where you start to plateau and then you
can move on to the next thing and so
maybe the thing right now with with the
work a whole workaholism yeah
workaholism is that ryan I want you to
not celebrate the crazy type a hundred
hour a week lifestyle but I also don't
want you to demonize it right that's
where I was trying to go with that
earlier discussion I want you to find
meaning in your work and so the problem
isn't the work the problem is is finding
the appropriate amount of meaning in our
work and growth and the ability to
contribute to other people's
that work he did say that if he he said
if I work less than 48 hours no no he
said if I if I if I stop working for
more than 48 hours I feel I'll go back
oh that's what it was okay I thought he
had a number on it but but to your point
I was just saying find that number
whatever that number is and in what I
was what I was getting at let's say the
number is 48 hours just going with that
number you know that that's and there
isn't a wrong number there meaning you
know Josh you and I we talked a lot
about all we work 6070 sometimes 80 hour
work weeks it was miserable it was it
was too much work sure but there are
weeks now where we might put in 60 hours
or more I mean when we were and that's
and also I think I think the reason
that's more palatable for me is I see
the light at the end of the tunnel there
is an objective there and it's not
sustainable to do that every single week
you like it's a temporary thing like we
know it's a temporary thing that that's
true and and so we know it's temporary
because we see that light at the end of
the tunnel right and we know it's not a
train it is it's like this outcome right
and so for us and sometimes we over
stretch it I mean I just wrote that
whole long apology essay and about the
need to say no sometimes you over
stretch it and so if you're working all
ik I just say find more meaning in the
work you love doing them and and right
now that's he's it's a liability right
being a worker turn that into an asset
Lee you want to work really hard work
hard on the right things and you'll feel
great about well yeah I was gonna say
well you know just stick sticking with
that example of like he he is he has
mastered this work find something else
to master so that doesn't mean you have
to leave your job but you know figure
out how many hours you want to work in a
week schedule your work around that and
what else can you can you do with the
the time that you freed up so maybe it
is maybe it's yoga like I don't know if
Ryan's around yogurt oh yeah that's
right yeah right so yes so pick one of
those things just one oh that's right I
forgot he totally did give us examples
so just pick one of those things so
let's say it is hiking great I find an
hour e of those
the same time craft beer with dad while
they're running on hiking trip he just
like put craft beer - camel pack your
jeez a workaholic he's a type-a guy
that's right that's right but yeah but
also I will say don't don't pressure
yourself to do all of it at once just
pick the thing that you feel like you're
going to enjoy the most mastering and in
store if you can give it an hour a week
great I had someone remember the the
person at the live event who was talking
about how they wanted to contribute more
but they had only like an hour a week
and I was like well then contribute an
hour a week like that's better than
nothing right and we trick ourselves
saying well if I can do only an hour I
might as well do nothing I can't do I'm
gonna do zero right it makes no sense
it's not by an area it is there there's
this whole spectrum of contribution or
work or whatever yeah and sometimes
there are seasons you'll have to work
more you have to work less hopefully
that work is meaningful for you and you
make time schedule time for those those
outside of work activities that your
other values let's call them I'd love to
send Ryan a copy of our book everything
that remains it was it really is the
story of our transition from some fairly
banal work I already have that book
judge otherwise oh okay from Connecticut
did you read it it's this transition we
know we worked in the corporate world
for a dozen years this fairly banal work
and transitioning into much more
meaningful work there's 12 chapters in
there about this journey from the
suit-and-tie corporate guys to becoming
the minimalist Ryan I think you'll find
some value in that book Sean if you can
reach out to him give him the audiobook
version or the book book version or the
eBook version whatever he wants all
right we'd love to hear what you all
have to say so if you have a comment or
a tip about the new year including
advice for any of our callers today then
leave us a voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3
9 you can also email a voice memo right
from your phone to podcast at the
minimalists comm it's my favorite part
of the show we air our favorite comments
and tips at the end of the show all
right Ryan what time is a its
time for our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media
indeed we are on Twitter Facebook and
Instagram at the minimalists during the
lightning round this is where Ryan and I
do our best to answer each question with
just a short Cheryl well less than 140
character responses like we got 280 now
well let's try to keep it to 140 if we
win animalist you're always trying to
one-up me but I suppose we could do it
in 280 if we really want to alright we
also put the text to these minimal
Maxim's in the show notes so you can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like and you can now
find all of our quotes in one place over
at minimal Maxim's com sometimes I just
go to that website and just read all of
my own pithy answers you know Ryan
you're so smart and pithy I just imagine
you like looking in the mirror says
pithy and lipstick the funny the
funniest thing is I will see people
tweet us occasionally give me a pithy
answer P iff why it's my favorite peanut
butter no I the the funny thing is like
I'll go back and look at some of these
the you know you're joking about going
back and look at minimal Maxim's ,
looking at but Jessica the one the GAO
who manages the the pithy answers she
does a really good job of like tweezing
out something that we say that is
profound amongst a a sea of of nonsense
yes and then she edited edits it for us
yeah yeah and it looks like wow that is
like a some sort of Zen Cohen or
something anyway Ryan all right our
first lightning round question is from
Virginia Virginia writes in how do you
inspire yourselves to keep in your
minimalist way year after year well I'll
give you my pithy answer and I'll try to
unpack it a little bit we needn't wait
for the new year to find a resolution
and so now is the time everyone is
clamoring for resolution but it
and of course what does a 90% of
resolutions are done by February light
like that people just given up and it's
because we put these these lofty lofty
goals objectives this picture of
ourselves and sometimes that can be
helpful but sometimes that could be
stifling yeah and that can prevent us
from taking action because we have this
affinity for perfectionism and you're
like well in order for me to for my life
to be perfect this year I have to
accomplish all of this and then it's
that thing we were just talked about a
moment ago it's oh it's all or nothing
and so I'm either going to be on this
perfect fast mimicking keto diet or I'm
going to eat seventeen ice cream
sandwiches right before bed mmm nice
cream sandwiches there's a crystal Lea
one of our favorite comics was certainly
one of my favorite comics he's hilarious
he he has this whole bit on his podcast
you should find the video Sean I think
put a link actually no you can't put a
link it's totally inappropriate show
notes but it's Rosa searches it on on
YouTube he has this whole thing about
portion sizes and eating a bunch of ice
cream sandwiches but yeah so don't wait
for the new year to find a resolution
and also you know your resolutions don't
have to be gigantic they can be one day
at a time
mm-hmm absolutely absolutely here's my
pithy answer minimalism isn't inspiring
living a meaningful life is hmm and you
know that's that's I guess really uh
that's kind of all I'm trying to say I
mean to unpack it I guess I would just
say that it's it's not about it's not
about looking at minimalism and getting
excited about minimalism getting excited
about decluttering sure those things can
certainly be exciting in the beginning
but ultimately minimalism isn't exciting
it is it is it is it is a tool that I
use to help me live a meaningful life
living a meaningful life that is what is
exciting and ultimately that is what
gives me the leverage that is what
inspires me to continue living this
lifestyle
there were users tool like I went to go
buy drill bits the other day because I'm
doing a frontal lobotomy on Ella what
it's fine I read about it in this old
Arundel you you know the the the what's
the opposite of frontal that's the way
you do it Josh we got to go through the
back Oh
the frontal lobe
go through the back of the lobe she's
still healing so we'll see how that goes
no I had but usually I bought these
tools and like I can understand like I
know some guys who I really have her
into there I mean we've talked to plenty
of oh yeah I'm really into my tool
collection but if it's just a tool
collection for the sake of being a
collection then it's you're you're
hoarding junk right and and so that you
could do the same thing with minimalism
where you fetish sighs the the act of
letting go without using it as a tool
like I really like this hammer I really
like this drill I really like this
chainsaw and the question is how are you
gonna use that hopefully you use it to
live a more meaningful life and that's
what is inspiring absolutely our next
question is from Nick how do you handle
taking a leap of faith into something
creative in a new year when you have no
idea where it's going to go or how
viable it is so the pithy answer that I
have and then hopefully I'll be able to
break this down here the direction is
more powerful than the destination so I
I also wrote down this quote from one of
my favorite guys on Twitter his name's
TK Coleman he said dreams don't come
true decisions do Oh amen that's good
man and so so it's really about making a
decision and so how do you handle taking
a leap of faith you have to make the
decision to actually do it you have to
make the damn decision as opposed to
just dreaming about whatever it is that
that you want to accomplish it whether
it's in the new year or the new month or
this week or today the decisions are
we're gonna what's gonna make your dream
come true not not just the dream itself
and so the only other thing I'll ask for
Nick or anyone else he was struggling
with this is how do you think something
great happens it's always one day at a
time if you write a book it's one word
at a time it's one page at a time
and it's one small step at a time it's
not just always that gigantic leap and
they seem like a leap in retrospect you
you you wrote this book you went on this
tour you finished this art project
you opened a yoga studio you got a new
job as a cashier at the grocery store
down the street it may seem like a giant
leap but there are a bunch of steps that
got you there in time yeah absolutely
man my pet the answer is is this Nick
and entrepreneurs first step requires
bravery and then I got a little
parenthetical here and a little
stupidity yeah it's like being willing
to be stupid almost right I was just
listening to another podcast and they
were talking about how they gave these
four groups of people a group of lawyers
a group of CEOs a group of
kindergarteners and a group of recent
business MBAs graduates right so they
just graduate with their business degree
they gave them like 27 pieces of I don't
know the exact numbers here I think was
27 pieces of string spaghetti hardened
and one marshmallow a yard of yarn okay
and with those they had to build the
tallest structure possible okay and the
group that won were the kindergarteners
get out the second was the CEOs because
they have real-life experience oh wow
and third were the the lawyers fourth
were the recent business MBA graduates
because they became so analytical on
what they were doing and they they're
afraid of being judged the
kindergartners like just try this I
tried this now try this it doesn't
matter the judgment just try keep trying
to keep trying to keep trying it's that
little bit of stupidity you're talking
about there but you're gonna build the
tallest structure if you're willing to
be wrong from time to time yeah I love
that man but no it's it's it is
absolutely the hardest part I think for
any entrepreneur I mean when I think
about the steps that we've taken whether
was starting the website whether it was
publishing a book whether it was it was
saying yes to the documentary I mean
every single time and it's like we have
an idea of how we want something to be
we plan ahead as much as possible right
but ultimately like taking those first
steps and getting it going without
knowing how the the end result is going
to be is certainly the hardest part yeah
and also being a mean so maybe it's not
even stupidity it sometimes is ignorant
like right I had I known how many
minimalist bloggers there were out in
the world in 2010 when we started it
like I knew a for right and and and then
of course there were dozens if not
hundreds of others and now when you
think of minimalism and blogging you're
gonna think of us and a couple other
people basically and that's because had
I known there were a thousand other
people blogging about minimalism I was
just given up and I've been like wow
that's
it's an oversaturated space right and
and what do I have that's unique I don't
started beating myself up instead of
being the kindergartner and saying hey
let me build this thing really tall and
we went into it as kindergarteners in
fact our friend Colin right talks about
living a life as as both a grad student
and a kindergartner at the same time
approaching things with with both
attitudes like the grad student is gonna
get incremental growth and could try to
continue to further his or her education
the kindergartner is starting all over
and learning everything brand new and
that's the reason that he travels so
much is he's like I wanna I just want to
absorb everything brand new I want to
pretend on my kindergartner when I moved
to a new country and so I think and do
that you can be the kindergartner of of
your own destiny
that's Pythias Pythias that's good man
no I you know it's funny my mom she's I
I've talked about how she wants to be a
comedian and she's done done like a
couple open mic nights right and there
was one night where she was like oh you
knows okay like I think it you know it
was actually I think was her first shows
okay I got a couple laughs that was good
and and I'm like mom I'm like
congratulations like you you took the
the the hardest step which was getting
up in front of a crowd of people and if
you feel like you failed that's great
yeah like now you have that experience
of failing right and if you fail again
it's not gonna be nearly as difficult
right next time and those failures make
you get better at what you're doing yes
and and I also um you know explain to
her like even if you fail if there's one
person even though even if you did get
one laughs if there's one person that
you get a laugh out of like that that in
its own is still a success right and the
the next show we did there was I mean
she just kind of got up there and
rambled a little bit and wasn't a whole
lot of laughter right but this girl came
up to her afterwards and was like thank
you so much for getting I mean just like
pour her heart out like wow thinking my
mom and when we left him um looked at me
she was like just one person right and
I'm like yeah just one person mom
exactly and again it wasn't the best set
ever but it was she got more experience
from it and was still able to take away
something from it yeah it was improving
can you think of any face I put you on
blast with with your Newark incident
already did oh I can think of any
failures that within the last seven
years since starting the minimalists
that I've messed up on Oh back to the
minimalist Oh hold onto that first and
you're pretty you're pretty perfect Josh
thank you thank you so think about that
for a second we're also we have a couple
bonus overtime questions for our patreon
supporters we do something each week
called the minimalists private podcast
and so we're gonna answer these two
questions when we get over to that that
overtime podcast Lisa asks with a big
change coming up we're expecting a
newborn how do I keep my minimalist
philosophy strong amidst the chaos of
change and then Suzu asks how do we
inspire our family members to join us on
the road to shedding old stuff including
old detrimental habits without them
thinking it's just a fad I also don't
want them to feel like they would be
giving up too much so we'll be answering
both of those questions over on our
patreon feed this week you can join us
over there at the minimalists comm slash
support we also do a bunch of other cool
stuff for our patreon supporters because
this podcast 100% advertisement free
thanks to you and so we do that private
podcast by the way it shows up in your
regular
Podcast feed we're also going to be
putting some of our live events from
this past year in the patreon feed
exclusively for our patreon supporters
thank you so much for your support if
you are a supporter yep all right I did
think before we move on to this bonus
episode for our patrons I did think of
something the the biggest it wasn't a
failure because we learned a lot from it
but going doing the documentary in movie
theaters yeah was like that's one of
them it was just not the best decision
we've ever made
yeah I mean I in fact it's all hindsight
like we didn't know that going into it
and I think I think that's a really good
point we said that with dan Harris
recently we're out in New York and in
fact he's gonna be on this podcast later
this month he'll be our first like guest
kind of yeah I mean in in studio yes
yeah we're not gonna interviewing though
so because we don't we don't do
interviews but well to sit down and have
a conversation hopefully if you have
some questions for him you can you can
call us up leave us a question and we'll
have Dan answer a few of those questions
live on the air but he sat down with us
and he's working on some documentary and
he's like can you tell us lessons that
you've learned and it was almost like
all things I wouldn't do again like you
learned so much about what to do right
from the stuff that you failed on so
late we're joking earlier about hey Ryan
tell tell Greta what not to do so she
can but but that's exactly what we did
with Dan though we literally did hear
the best lessons I can give you our
things that we wouldn't do again right
hey could I have done it over it
yeah our documentary was a huge success
and I'm doing that in air quotes in
theaters it was the number one
independent documentary theatrical
release opening of 2016 and that is an
impressive stat by its own do you
realize that the amount of effort that
went into making that happen would have
just been much better spent on getting
it out in front of the public sooner and
right it was it was nice that we had
that sort of accolade but you and I
don't live for the accolades
and and the validation of well I want to
thank the Academy or whatever um and the
the real validation comes from people
getting value from the message and if
50,000 people salt in theatres yeah then
it's you know millions and millions of
people who have seen the documentary
online wouldn't you have rather just had
to come out online sooner and especially
with the the amount of effort and so you
see that and you look at it and it was a
type of failure even in its success was
a type of failure and of course all the
other stuff we did we submitted to I
just hate that word even submit and we
submitted to like a hundred film tussles
most of which denied us yeah all of the
big ones said no no no no thank you
and then we got into some mid-level or
small film festivals and what that tells
me is that you know what like I wouldn't
do that again it wasn't it wasn't worth
the amount of work that went into that
it's honestly kind of a racket they
charge you fifty or seventy-five bucks
to submit to their Film Festival yeah do
we yeah we spent a lot of money and I
mean was there anything we could say
that all we're really glad we were
really glad our film show you know
showed at this one particular Film
Festival because that created this
relationship with I mean I can't even
think of anything you know no not at all
man now it's not to say that it wasn't
worth trying it was worth trying got
some laurels yeah we did I was about it
yeah she was really nice laurels oh yeah
they were really they're really nice
okay now it's time for our added value
portion of the show this where we each
recommend or actually just talk about
something that has added value to our
lives
recently Ryan um man so I used to wear
American Apparel shirts they went out of
business you can still buy them in bulk
but they don't fit me right anymore
I don't know what happened so I went to
a place called son of a tailor and it is
it's unbelievable dude there are like I
have never recommended a black t-shirt
until today and use promo code nicodemus
no there's no promo code now wait
because they're kind of expensive and
that's actually the thing they are
expensive so when I say expensive if you
order two t-shirts you're gonna probably
pay like 50 bucks apiece maybe 60 bucks
apiece but here's the thing is like you
you send in your measurements and they
the tailor a t-shirt specifically for
you in which is what you need cuz your
your biceps are so big that's right
exactly
well I have this picture of you with
with my mom I know no that that's a
different picture
let's not talking about that one mom
wearing a you know like a turban or
something on her head and because she oh
she was going through chemo yeah and you
had you were hot you had one arm around
her like you know the side hug - yeah
photo and you're wearing you speaking of
organizer you you flew down to Florida
to visit my me and my mom remember this
is 2009 yes and you forgot to pack any
t-shirts so you would - I was just in
like emergency mode man you went to this
surf shop and you just bought like all
the graphic tees they have and so I've
got this I've got this picture of you
with your arm around my mom and she's
short corporate haircut and you kind of
buff and like you you have on the shirt
it has weapons of mass destruction and I
have another one you fell asleep on a
couch at a coffee shop down there yeah
you were hella yeah you were in this
shirt that uh with a camel on it just
has one a home
oh those 20 so good no so son of a son
of a tailor it is it is like basically
if you buy 10 t-shirts then you pay way
lest coz like they're gonna make more
for you they're gonna they're gonna
charge you less so I always put that
when I like recommend something that
costs a little bit of money although
this isn't like you know the end of the
world but uh it's such a good thing it's
like if you can afford it you don't put
it on a credit card it's totally worth
it yeah I I agree or if you can find a
shirt that fits you well without going
through that I got the shirt I'm wearing
right now on eBay yeah that's another
option so there are plenty of options
out there you know my problem is is I
have such a weird body shape yeah you
sleep a broad shoulders super broad
shoulders
big chest it's like it's a very odd it's
a very odd
rynason found a late a weight that he
can't lift that's right
I just lift all the ways anyway my added
value is there's an album I've been
playing out and and I don't think it's a
good thing but Ella sings along to it
quite a bit it's a the new album from
Belly called mumble rising belly don't
tell back oh my god impacts is totally
Beck's is playing in the car and it's
that's the reason to elinoz yeah some of
the songs anyway one of my favourite
albums of the year I will put a link to
in the show notes belly
it's called mumble rap although it's not
mumble rap at all it's in fact it's the
opposite of whatever though no it's like
making it's like I'm assuming it's
probably like making fit satire like the
yeah the title itself is like hey this
is the climate we're in so I'm just
gonna call it this but it's obviously
not mobile right yeah it's it's a great
album really well produced one of my
favorite albums of the year all right
let's move on to right here right now
this is where we talk about what's going
on in the lives of the minimalist
speaking of favorite albums of the year
if you head on over to the minimalists
calm slash sound each year i put out a
list of my favorite ten twelve eight
whatever the list is albums of 2017 ryan
did you have any favorite albums really
stood out to you oh man I think I know
your favorite and it's
my top five oh man I'm like drawing a
blank right now cuz there's so many
there was there was Andrew bells which
was great that's mine that's number two
on my list the killers I love that new
album that's the honorable mention on my
list um
the Canyon City album is great that is
number one on my list the what else what
else what else
um so I like jay-z's album that came out
I liked number eight on my list jay-z
Eminem's new mom just came out it was
it's actually growing on me a little bit
that's honorable mention for me it's
unbeliev when I don't listen to Eminem's
first the whole album through I was like
oh my goodness I'm like why yeah well
I'm like this is it like I understand
he's having fun he's doing what he loves
but I was thinking like if I was an
artist at that point I would just
produce stuff I would never like promote
it like I would just put it online like
I wanted I wanted the 444 of yes of
Eminem yeah cuz jay-z made what I think
is JC's best or second best album yeah
for 44 it's his most mature for sure
yeah I was expecting the same thing but
what I will say is that listening to it
a couple times it actually is it does go
I feel like it does dive it does dive
pretty deep yeah he has a song called
bad husband on there that is I mean
about how he really I mean it's the
opposite of how he used to you know he's
to kill his ex-wife and songs right uh
what two decades ago or whatever it was
but now he's like two decades ago super
funny yeah but now he's admitting to
like being a bad husband and and and
it's also this sort of cultural critique
of well yeah we often are bad husbands
with good fathers and we like we say
that that's a good thing but no that
doesn't that doesn't advocate us for the
mistakes and bad decisions that we made
during our our marriage if we weren't
there for our partner so what did you
think when number one of them was Khalid
Oh which is number five on my list
American teen I did not even realize
that was that was uh this that was this
year I thought that was the end of last
year no that was toward the beginning of
this year definitely one of my favorite
album so you can check out my whole list
top ten
shir you found all my past year's list
since I've been doing this I think since
2011 and a bunch of honorable mentions
this year as well honestly Ryan I think
2017 was the best year for music in a
long time yeah in the least since 2013
but maybe even even farther back from it
was a great great year for for music so
you check that out that's going on in
the lives of the minimalist what else we
got going on here Ryan I don't know but
but you're right though Khalid would be
my favorite album I knew it was like you
were playing that album hard so since
we've been back in studio there since
we're back in Sudan we've been on the
road there are a bunch of new essays
over at the minimalists comm so while
you're over there checking out that list
of my favorite albums you can find a
bunch of new writings from the
minimalists you can find that si si I
did about the apology and the need to
say no it's called an apology and the
need to say no basically just go over to
the minimalists comm you can scroll
scroll through all the archive archives
over there another recent one was about
Black Friday called let's talk about
Black Friday you had some thoughts about
the holiday shopping season you had a
video that we made about the the bag
that we produced the the packed bag you
can check that out everything that I
pack whenever I'm on the road whether
it's a year or a a month or a day you
can see everything that I packed for
that a couple my favorite essays
recently it was one I wrote called have
to get to and it talks about waking up
at 4:30 in the morning on a Thursday and
the framing of that day there was
another essay called redefining better
where a recent event a tiny house
enthusiast came up to me and asked me
about the size of my house
and what I told her was a little bit
Freud say about that well I'll just read
the first paragraph from that essay at a
recent event a tiny house enthusiast
asked me about the size of my home when
I told her it's probably around a
thousand square feet her response was
you could do better
and and then so I saw asked myself that
question throughout the SS it really
could my family and I in fact do better
depends what you mean by better and then
I go into like how do we redefine what
better means because smaller doesn't
mean better less doesn't necessarily
mean better fewer doesn't necessarily
mean better what does better mean how do
we how do we redefine that I was essay
on there called Las Vegas and other ways
to contribute we talked about some of
the ways the the minimalist have been
able to contribute to charitable causes
this year we had a good question about
conspicuous consumption that wrote a
long essay on about that what else we
have here all you can find all of our
old podcasts on here as well and then
there's one other one that was really
good all those the three free minimalist
wallpapers you can find those on there
for your phone or your computer those
are all free and Oh a special kind of
freedom this was one of my favorite
essays I've written in a while so you
can find that one there as well so a
bunch of those and if you want all of
those show up in your inbox whenever we
publish a new essay or the notes to the
podcast you can just sign up for our
email list over at the minimalists com
of course we'll never ever send you spam
because that stuff's disgusting oh
experiment so that's January now it's
not when we're recording this or
recording this like December 21st but
its January now yes and we are off
social media for the month of January
and yeah yeah and I think we're gonna
learn a lot of lessons this month taking
a month off and find a way to repurpose
reuse refocus our efforts on social
media in a way that isn't just posting
everything in triplicate let's put that
on Instagram and and Facebook and
Twitter and post this picture they're an
announcement here no we want to use
these platforms effectively differently
more intentional yeah we want to be able
to be communicative and expressive and
and and let these be an extension of the
minimalists without just being this
broadcasting promo machine and I talked
about this in the apology essay that I
wrote is like man I felt like I even saw
it in my own work where it was I was
becoming too promo heavy well I mean we
try to keep our audience informed
right and I think I think you could do
that and that's why I like we talk do we
do this right here right now segment
well the problem is is like some people
don't listen to the podcast
some people don't look at social media
some people don't look at the blog so
you know I feel like we have to mention
everything on every single platform but
it to your point though it's it's it's
it's it's become to our detriment yeah
and so we have to be we I think what
we're gonna learn throughout part of
this and to what degree I'm not sure but
we have to be ok with the you know it's
the fear of missing out right well not
everyone's gonna hear about now of
course I know 99 it's ok world doesn't
know who the minimalists are and that's
ok right there are a lot of people
without an internet connection who are
never going to hear about us and that's
okay and so we're not going to beat you
over the head with stuff we'll do a
segment like right here right now where
we can talk about what's going on our
lives we could talk about if we have an
event or something going on but we're
not gonna beat you over the head with
with the stuff we we have going on so
we're learning a lesson we'll probably
post an essay almost certainly will
write an essay about what the non social
media experience brought about what what
what did it birth in terms of how we're
gonna use social media differently
starting in February so stay tuned for
that and be on our email list and you'll
be the first to to read that also we're
headed to already mention this revenue
Australia in March you can get your
tickets over at the minimalists com we
have two more stops in the United States
one is in Vegas so we ended the less is
now tour last year I am like trying to
Rack my brain for the second stuff well
you will get there so so we ended the
lesson out or for 2017 in Milwaukee the
this year and man it was great so we're
doing we did 42 cities last year we
almost had to reschedule that man it was
so close this is the very very light
goodness we made it happen yeah but so
so we we have a charity event in Las
Vegas because of the there was a tragedy
to happen there and we're donating a
hundred percent of the profits from that
to the Las Vegas Victims Fund our friend
Matt dia Vela is going to be there with
us from the ground up show he'll be
answering questions on stage with us and
then in
February we're going to be in Los
Angeles we're filming two events right
as the most hustle I'm like I'm like the
week we did we take on a speaking
engagement nobody I do I told no I
totally forgot about this so the
minimalists are filming a new
documentary and it's a follow-up to our
Netflix documentary minimalism a
documentary about the important things
and we're filming a new documentary it's
called the minimalist Celeste is now and
and so Ryan you and I have presented
this less is now tour talk in front of
dozens of audiences throughout 2017 and
we're finally going to capture it on
film we did so on a few stages Matt
helped us out with that but it wasn't
the aesthetic we're looking for so we're
going to capture it in this beautiful
warehouse space in Los Angeles you can
find a picture of that space over on our
website the minimalists comm slash
warehouse and we're inviting some folks
to attend we're actually doing two
tapings it's a 3 p.m. taping and a 7
p.m. taping we just added so 3 p.m.
tapings sold out in a few hours and
there are still a few tickets left for
the 7 p.m. taping by the time this comes
up my guess is there might be a few left
totally up to you if you want to
participate in that just real quick the
new film that we're working on it's
gonna combine that in-depth talk that we
give about minimalism with some sort of
documentary style footage of our
personal lives our journeys and our
backstories I think it's where
minimalism sort of the documentary
minimalism scratch the the surface of
our journeys this new film is going to
really dig deep into the events that led
us towards simplifying our own lives so
if you want to be part of the audience
it's February 10th 2018 it's in Los
Angeles at electric Pony studios you
have to get your tickets in advance is
an all-ages event it's about 90 minutes
it's our talk we've given this last year
seats are limited to the first 300
people so you just go to the minimalists
comm and click on the the tour page
there you can find the the times and
dates we hope to see you out there we're
really looking forward to getting that
on film oh it's going to be
a couple other things here if you go to
the minimalists comm slash simple year
it is a new year our friend Courtney
Carver who just had a new book coming
out called soulful simplicity we'll put
a link to that in the show notes but she
also has this year-long course that we
participated in a few times and it is
open up once again and it's called a
simple year during the month of January
it's a year-long 12 months of guided
simplicity just go to the minimalists
comm slash simple year if you want some
I don't think you need of course to
simplify your life but if you need a
little help a little guidance as 12
different experts sohow guide you
through the entire year each month yeah
I mean it's it's a great it's a great
accountability tool if you're looking
for an accountability partner yeah
exactly and and and people to not hold
your hand well sometimes it's holding
your hand right sometimes they'll push
you they'll drag you kicking and
screaming - to simplicity not not really
but they will help you along the way
twelve different experts on twelve
different topics so it's tackling one
topic per month so that could be
decluttering it can be holiday shopping
gift-giving that's the one that Ryan and
I really dive deep on and that's our
month and then it could be travel it
could be minimalist family and that
there are the all of these different
topics that you can dive into all the
information over at the minimalists comm
slash simple year and oh speaking of
resetting resetting your year My partner
Rebecca has a new new course it's a 23
day reset and it is over at minimal
wellness comm and I think there's only
30 seats available to us I don't know if
there's any left but if there are you
can find that she's also doing an
automated version of that where you
don't have to meet with her if you just
want to take the course on-line alright
that's about it right now we just have
we have additional bonus this week on
patreon for our patreon supporters we're
going to post our Tampa event over there
and so we answered a bunch of questions
at that Tampa event because we're back
in studio now we're going to be doing a
lot more studio episodes throughout this
year we're gonna take some of those live
events and put them in our exclusively
in our patreon feed over in that the
minimalists private podcast which will
show up in your regular podcast
app whatever you listen to this on it
now you just need that private link so
some of the questions we answer at that
tample of them if I'm upside down on the
mortgage on my house should I pay more
on it now or should I put the money in
the bank and pay on requisite repairs
right before I sell it you know it's
interesting Ryan lay I'd be interested
to see how we answer these questions now
versus live because sometimes that
adrenaline really helps you give this
great beautiful answer
I gotta Ryan like just pull that answer
right out the thin air and give it and
then you answer it now and I can have
notes or whatever in front of my guess
is the answers would be different cuz
sometimes I go back and listen those
live events and I'm say man I had the
perfect answer four hours after the
event when I was laying awake and always
works yeah it seems to be but then
there's sometimes that adrenaline like
gives me the best possible answer I'm
like oh my god how did I how did I have
that answer yeah some other questions we
answer on that live Tampa podcast is
gonna come out this Friday by the way on
that patreon feed if I don't receive
support from my loved ones when I adopt
new empowering habits and practices what
should I do
how do I address my partner's hoarding
tendencies how do I get everyone on
board with minimalism and a
multi-generational household and how can
I become more conscientious regarding my
consumption of media especially the
media on the Internet so some of the
questions we answer on this Friday's
live episode also we had our friend's
brother Cephas who were on my top ten
list they they opened up for us and they
played a song on that podcast as well
all right Ryan anything else in the
right here right now anything else going
on your life you want to talk about yeah
man I got some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners
hey this is Elliot from Minneapolis uh I
just wanted to make a comment about this
recent
Christmas and holiday season you know I
was really worried about all the stuff
and everything that comes with it and I
kind of took a look at everything that
was in my room and everything that I
didn't need or didn't want and that
didn't add value to my life and so I
decided that I would donate it to this
charity cause for my school and that was
honestly one of the most fulfilling
gifts I think I got and I think that I
could give so I just wanted to make a
comment saying you know if you have all
this stuff and you're worried about you
know stuff for Christmas one thing that
I did was I took a look at everything
that I had already and I put stuff that
doesn't add value to my life in a bag
and I donate it to a cause that might
add value to some others I don't know if
this comment said already but that's all
I wanted to say hi this is kira I'm a
student at UCSB and I am a big fan of
the minimalist your guys's messages and
everything for the most part but there
is one thing that I think is important
to kind of makes clear from my own
experiences around health and nutrition
and diet and what that all means so I
personally hat and right now recovering
from an eating disorder and and it was
confusing for me I think to listen to
you guys and to about Leah Baba's story
that minimalism and all this positive
radical life change went along with
weight loss but I actually needed to
gain weight and exercise less and that
seemed counterintuitive and just like
how minimalism is like a middle way
minimalism is not about deprivation you
guys say that I think that health and
exercise should be the same thing
so you don't necessarily have to just
prescribe to a single diet it's really
about finding balance and same with
exercise it should all come from a place
of loving your body rather than what you
should do because it does feel good
exercise and eat well but everything in
moderation and so for me personally
exercise and diet became anchors and
restrictive behaviors that were kind of
prohibiting me from social interactions
and other positive things and so for me
removing those anchors and focusing on
what is what's positive in my life meant
gaining weight and that was a healthy
thing for me hi this is Lauren I live in
New Orleans forgive me if this tip has
been used in one form or another on your
podcast I just started listening this
year and haven't completely caught up on
all of the episodes but I was cleaning
out my clothes closet and dresser this
morning and wanted to share my tip for
keeping a minimalist wardrobe so in my
dresser and my closet I have stacks of
items underwear socks shirts shorts
jeans etc all of my different clothing
items are in stacks when I do laundry I
put the clean items at the bottom of
each stack so the items that I haven't
worn most recently and up at the top of
the stack and I tried to choose items to
wear from the top each day that way if I
find myself not well not willing to wear
something that's on the top of the stack
because I don't like it anymore or it
doesn't fit anymore then I know it's
probably time to get rid of it I also do
this with my hanging clothes I will put
the laundered items on the right side
and try to choose items to wear from the
left side so they're also constantly
rotating consequently I only had a small
bag of items to get rid of during
today's purge because I wear most of the
items that I own all right Joe that's it
for this episode you have a question for
the minimalists give us a call for 0 6 2
1 9 7 8 3 9
you can also email a voice memo right
from your phone to podcast at the
minimalists comm and if you leave here
with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for and you got a grin oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you
so tear your teen
[Music]
you
[Music]